hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar downstream processing
challenges in cell therapy manufacturing
I'm Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll
be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by two room OB CT
two room OB CT a global leader in blood
component therapeutic apheresis and
cellular technologies believes in the
potential of blood and cells to do even
more for patients than they do today
true Moby C T's cell therapy
technologies business enables
researchers developers and manufacturers
to create next-generation cell and gene
therapies to learn more visit
www.opm.gov/life Tubb your screen
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button questions will be answered
after the presentation to enlarge the
slide window click on the arrows at the
top right hand corner of the
presentation window if you experience
technical problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by typing it into the answer a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process of
obtaining your credits I now present
today's speakers Jim Belcher PhD in
Geoffrey you'll MBA who are both from
Teramo BC t dr. belt sir is the senior
manager of global strategic medical
affairs for cell therapy technologies he
recently transitioned to this team to
better leverage his technical background
and the commercial exposure he's gained
during
more than seven years at the company
prior to joining the cell processing
team at Jerome obesity doctor Belcher
was the lead scientist at Corning Life
Sciences for the Rd of synthamax a
synthetic growth surface the culture of
human embryonic stem cells he was a
co-founder of red corporation and was a
key player in the industrialization of
several technology platforms including
phage display and yeast two-hybrid he
has more than 25 years of industrial
research and development experience in a
broad range of disciplines
Jeffrey Yule is the senior engineering
manager for cell processing Jeff leads
the product development efforts the cell
therapy technologies portfolio he
previously led teams engaged in the
development of single-use disposable
medical devices across several to room
obesity product lines prior to joining
the company Jeff developed complex
electromechanical systems in the fields
of medical simulation and laboratory
instrumentation throughout his 18-year
career Jeff is earned three US patents
for his contributions to product
development efforts
Jim Beltre and Jeff you'll will now
begin their presentations
like to present some of the challenges
that are that we face in downstream
processing for cell therapy
manufacturing
my agenda today will be first to review
the regenerative medicine marketplace
and then I'd like to talk about where we
are what's the state of the art in cell
therapy manufacturing like to review
some of the upstream manufacturing
decisions that we make as we're doing
process development and the main part of
the talk will be downstream processing
technologies overview with a highlight
at the at the very end highlighting the
the true moe Taniya fill and finish
system
so the regenerative mark medicine market
worldwide there's about 900 companies
that are working in the in this space so
it is very well representative all
around the world right now and is
growing as you can see at the end of
2017 there were 770 so remarkable growth
in this space if you look at the number
of clinical trials that are going on in
this space you see that we have over a
thousand clinical trials at the end of
2018 that's up from 200 of roughly 200
from 2017 and you can see that they're
pretty well distributed between gene
therapy gene modified cell therapy and
cell therapy with a few tissue
engineering projects or clinical trials
as well finally most of those trials are
in oncology cardiovascular and
musculoskeletal issues come in second
and third pretty much all of the the
indications that are in normal big
pharma indications are targeted by
regenerative medicine as well
so this is a slide from john rowley of
rooster bio and he's promoting the
product cycle model of innovation and in
this slide he shows what he says is that
the cell therapy product innovation
curve is a bit on the downhill slope but
the cell manufacturing process
innovation curve is very much on the
upslope so sort of logarithmic growth if
you will so he said we are now in a
phase of maximum increase of the rate of
manufacturing process innovation now I
may argue with it John whether or not we
are actually on a downhill slide of cell
therapy product innovation I would argue
that we're not but I do agree with John
that we are in a phase of innovation for
cell therapy manufacturing and Krish
really over at the Georgia Tech has set
up the National cell manufacturing
consortium and they have decided to
support three separate manufacturing
platforms so MSDS for regenerative
medicine car T cells for cancer
immunotherapy and finally IPSC
cardiomyocytes for cardiac regenerates
regeneration applications
along with accepting those challenges so
the national film manufacturing
consortium is trying to establish best
practices for cell therapy manufacturing
and they've identified a number of gaps
that they're addressing so in addition
to looking at three different
manufacturing platforms there they're
trying to learn how the process affects
cell quality and thereby derived news CQ
A's
critical quality attributes our new
safety tests efficacy and potency assays
additionally they're trying to develop
new tools and I'm sure everybody has
heard about in line testing sensors
you know real-time image processing so a
lot of lot of new new tools that need to
be invented at this stage and finally
the goal is to how to do how to develop
high quality large scale and local cost
cells for regenerative medicine and
that's important that we try to
understand if the product is the process
so if we have isolation expansion
sorting we need to understand how that
process is affecting ourselves because
unlike biologics were actually
introducing live cells into the as the
drug product so a cell therapy roadmap
this is really the process that you go
through from starting at the bench where
you have just demonstrated clinical
value to a specific disease through your
experiments that looks promising so you
go into process development to develop
manufacturing and testing finally if
you're going to actually do that testing
you may have to scale up so increase
yield decrease cost especially if you're
trying to commercialize all of this so
as this cell therapy process evolves
here you can see that there are little
arrows connecting these boxes so that if
the change is made as you're scaling up
in your process remember the product is
the process you may have to go all the
way back to the discovery phase in order
- to make changes to assure yourself
that you haven't changed the cells in
that and finally in the last stage we
get to deliver a preclinical and
clinical manufacturing so this is a
traditional cell therapy manufacturing
roadmap so remember this process that
I've shown just before here is happening
in this context as well so if we make
this shows here at the beginning we have
cell line development master cell bank
and working cell bank and cell culture
so that's really just up to the
expansion phase and what we're going to
talk about today is basically after the
harvest so in addition we have chances
to affect the quality of ourselves as we
go through cell wash and concentrate to
emulate fill and finish crowd
preservation and shipping and all before
getting to the end user handling steps
so here's one way to look at some of the
process development decisions that we
make as we're developing a process for
cells so this is just a different way to
look at the same material so you can see
the manufacturing process is broken up
into large tasks here we have tissue
procurement cell manufacturing storage
distribution and patient administration
now the gray arrow underneath shows
really what's on the company's mind so
in the beginning we're worried about the
cost per million cells as we're
developing cells to deliver to patients
once we understand our treatment well
enough it's going to be in safe phase
one will be interested in the cost per
dose or the cost per treatment as we
scale up and it's only really at the
last box our last the end of this cycle
when we get to patient administration
that we can actually make some of that
money back so we want to look at how
those development process development
decisions affect the cost of your
process and how many of them are baked
in from the very beginning of the
process and the first is this tissue
procurement so we have basically a
couple of choices we can go with
autologous cell expansions or we can go
with allergen a excel expansion so
obviously the market would like to have
off-the-shelf solutions and the allergen
tank is deemed to be less expensive
because of centralized processing and
scale-up and we only have one or one or
a few donors to validate you do have
additional concerns as you worry about
cold chain and transport autologous
presents other challenges so it's
usually typically a multicenter process
there will be scale out rather than
scale up and donor variability is one of
the big problems you'll be struggling
with here
now if we want to look at the cell
manufacturing piece of this so we here
we have lots of buckets materials is the
first ones facility and processing so
processing is probably the part that we
most think about as cell therapy
manufacturing that's the cell expansion
but believe me there's a lot that goes
on before then so in materials you could
be making decisions about the base media
whether you're going to use serum or
serum free media
what growth factors needed to be need to
be added to keep themselves healthy and
happy if you're using a single-use
disposable just remember that you'll be
locked into that disposal through the
life of the product you may have to buy
micro carriers or activation beads or
self sorting materials magnetic beads
you'll have to purchase release agents
cryoprotectant freezing bags vials
excipients so the number of decisions
around your initial materials is huge in
the beginning of your process
development in the facility it's sort of
the same argument as what your choices
are going to be for autologous versus
allergenic so if you have fresh product
and you're going to have a multicenter
with a complex technology transfer
that's going to be more expensive than a
frozen product maybe even sent to a
central processing or a CMO similarly if
you're working with your labor costs are
going to be lower if you've got closed
systems and automated systems than with
open planar based culture where
and finally we get to the processing
this is the traditional decisions that
you think about when you're scaling up
or scaling out or even just developing a
regenerative medicine process so the lot
size determines your hardware and you
then get the choice between a stirred
tank bioreactor plus or minus micro
carriers hollow fiber bio reactors
multi-layer stacks or flask based
systems and it's important to remember
that as you increase the number of cells
you're producing in the expansion step
that you're increasing or producing
actually a downstream processing
bottleneck with those increased numbers
of cells so finally just in summary of
those process development decisions it
looks like a lot of your cost is
centered around labor and materials
current processes and I think this is
true of the industry we're lacking
automation and manpower and as I've just
pointed out many of your process
decisions are made early in process to
development autologous versus allergenic
materials from media to freezer bags
facilities lot size and what type of
expansion system whether it's a stirred
tank or a hollow fiber bioreactor
so if we look at what we've covered so
far we've really only covered the first
part of our therapeutic delivery roadmap
and now I'd like to concentrate on some
of the downstream processing choices
that we have so this is just the big
buckets here I put out so downstream
processing choices are after harvest we
have rinse reliefs quench and test those
cells we have a cell wash and
concentrate reduced volume here so that
can be done through centrifugation
tangential flow filtration or
elutriation technology or otherwise
known as counter flow centrifugation we
have cryo vials freezer bags and and
other types of sealed vials to choose
from and we get to choose our storage
whether it's liquid nitrogen or
refrigerated so this is just a general
downstream processing checklist I've
sort of bolded the table stakes so I'd
say a downstream processing with
downstream process would need to be a
GMP compliant would need to include some
automation single-use disposable fully
closed scaleable the biggest problem
you're going up against here is you want
to keep the processing time as small as
possible label-free obviously you don't
get all of these choices in every
product so we'll go ahead and talk about
some of these downstream processing
choices here we go
so downstream processing limitations the
bottom like I'm going to talk first
about MSC processes because we have a
short time window to transfer the cells
from culture medium and in the case of
MSC culture medium and attach to a
surface to the crowd preserve sit state
so in a freezer vial or bag it with a
crowd protectant and at minus 130 to 150
degrees centigrade so Jocelin at Al the
reference I have at the bottom of the
screen here I've stated that for
alginate production that's capacity
right now in 2008
is limited to around 150 to 200 liters
per batch just because of that limited
processing time you don't want your
cells at the beginning right after
harvest to be different to the cell to
go into the freezer so first step we're
going to be thinking about detaching
those cells are MFCs from the
supernatant and we'll need to optimize
time pH temperature and enzymatic
quenching as part of our process
development so each part of each method
will have a specific process for
harvesting so in the case of stirred
tank bio reactors now we'll have MSC s
on micro carriers and in this particular
case you'll want to have a dissociation
agent probably a recombinant one like
trypsin or Tripoli or triple select and
then to release the cells from those
micro carriers you'll want to increase
the impeller agitation so those are
those two facts are actually could
contribute to a decrease in their
critical quality attributes of yourself
so we want to make sure that we keep
ourselves as healthy and happy as as
possible so we want to keep our
harvesting efficiency a greater than 95%
when we want to keep ourselves healthy
and happy in order to do that in a
stirred tank bioreactor we have to take
into consideration the stresses put on
shear stresses put on by the stirrer by
the impeller and so I'll talk briefly in
the next slide about the coal mater
off-scale which seeks to tame those
forces and then finally just one last
point for MSC s on micro carriers it
saves time and reduce the steps if you
actually do that
release step in the expansion chamber
so now to talk about the Kolmogorov
scale and impeller speed so on the left
hand side of the of the figure you can
see micro carriers in red and the
streamlines are the the eddies are the
shear force in blue and as long as those
streamlines are larger or spaced larger
than the micro carriers then there will
be very little damage to the cells very
little shear damage to the cells
if however as is shown on the and the
case on the right your shear lines are
closer together and smaller than the
actual micro carrier again shown in red
here and you have the possibility of
shear damage to your cells grown on
those beads so this is a very simplistic
case of managing this process there are
more much more sophisticated ways of
doing it
finally if we're harvesting from a
hollow fiber or a packed bed bioreactor
will require also require a release
agent but now we don't have all the same
tools now we can increase the time and
we can increase our pump speed or the
flow rate or maybe even the rotation of
a culture vessel alternatively you could
use different environmentally responsive
polymers that would eliminate the need
for trypsin or recombinant release
agents these environmentally responsive
polymers react to temperature or to pH
one of the criticisms is that they may
result in cell sheets being formed
rather than single cell suspensions
so once the cells are released from the
substrate or released from the micro
carriers we need to quench the trypsin
EDTA release agents in the solution this
can be done with media containing serum
with a serum with a trypsin inhibitor by
dilution by simply washing out Andry
suspending in fresh media now downstream
processing obviously we don't want to
infuse the patient with micro carriers a
couple of different ways these are the
old-school ways to get rid of micro
carriers in the process cells after
harvest they both involve a swinging
buckets interrogation or dead-end
filtration so both of these methods are
not easily automated and so we'll talk
about a couple of alternatives to these
tried-and-true although manual methods
the first I'd like to present is counter
flow centrifugation or elutriation and
this can be found in true most Lutra and
in sartorius's case set and here we have
a fluidized bed for low shear so you can
see on the far right the centrifugation
forces towards the floor in this
particular diagram but we have a counter
flow of media the small arrow pointing
towards the ceiling here at the bottom
of the fluid eyes bed chambers so this
is good for reducing volume washing and
can handle lot sizes up to hundreds of
liters
now the first two field flow
fractionation techniques I put a big
stamp of experimental on these they're
used probably coming soon to it to a
cell process near you but not quite
ready for primetime the acoustic wave
filtration right now it's best used and
used in small microfluidic platforms so
scale is an issue there and
dielectrophoresis where we're basically
using an electric field instead of a
membrane and that can be used to select
rare cells now two techniques that are
often used in cell therapy manufacturing
usually the characterized cells but the
fluorescence activated cell sorting and
magnetic activated cell sorting are on
the last category here and they have a
drawback in that they require labeling
but they are both highly selective and
they are very essential to our
characterization studies but perhaps not
to wash and concentrate steps another
method that's quite in fact it's
probably the most commonly used in the
wash room concentrate is tangential flow
filtration and here we have a bundle of
hollow fibers usually pre-sterilized
it's got monitors to make sure that it
doesn't foul so it's got integrated
pressure sensors and you can see here
that that the cells stay in the hollow
fibers whereas the permeate is allowed
to pass through the hollow fibers into
and away from the cells
and at this point in the process we
would be looking for automated fill and
finish so keep that in mind I'm going to
continue on with the process here but we
will be talking about in more detail
about Tremeloes fill and Phinehas fill
and finished system in a few moments so
now as we move so now we've watched and
concentrated we've filled and finished
our cells we're going to do controlled
rate freezing so it's important to
freeze your cells below minus 130
degrees C it was stated that that is
that all measureable biological activity
ceases below that number I think that's
interesting optimal flow optimal post
thaw or cell survival means that we
freeze very slowly and as we will talk
about at the end is that once we have
frozen them that the thawing is actually
the opposite of stalling very quickly so
one samples we reach minus 80 they can
be transferred to the vapor phase of
liquid nitrogen now we'll have a crowd
preservation formulation this would have
gone in before usually consists of DMSO
and a storage media that optimizes ionic
strength pH and free radical scavengers
so those formulated cells would go into
either cryo vials for our bags and those
bags and vials need to be submergible in
liquid nitrogen and they shouldn't be
contributing more particulate this is
one one of the constant concerns of
folks packaging and doing final fill and
finish for cells is that you don't want
to introduce more particulates into the
patient finally cold chain is a big
issue and it actually starts at the very
beginning when you acquire yourselves or
your tissues and continues until you
actually reintroduce the cells into the
patient
for short-term storage and transport you
want to maintain that temperature here I
have minus 150 but we're really talking
about short trips four hours less than
half a day
liquid nitrogen absorbed in an on
Stillwell format with date time and
temperature alarms both audible and
visual and the old lab tip trick of
using styrofoam and dry ice is really
not acceptable for this storage for
longer trips we would need to maintain
that temperature for up to seven days
and again we use liquid nitrogen and
these containers can safely transport
hundreds of miles and they continuously
log the temperature inside and outside
during shipping and finally you'll need
an archival storage tank to keep all of
these cells for as long as the patients
are still being treated and so you'll
need large liquid nitrogen storage tanks
finally when the cells are delivered to
the patient's rapid thawing as I've
already hinted at is the best way to
maintain high viability and so to do
that I think we need to automate this
step as well so a solid-state device is
preferable water bath result in
incomplete thawing higher contamination
risk and they're not really GMP
compatible so
with that I'd like to introduce Jeff
you'll will discuss the Affinia fill and
finish system so pictured here is the
fitting of fill and finish system which
is an automated system for final
formulation and filling of
cryopreservation bags so the device is
fully automated and it utilizes a
sterile single-use disposable that is
functionally closed throughout the
process it maintained functionally close
by connecting incoming materials with a
Teramo sterile connection device the
finial fill and finish system can cool
incoming products it can mix them to
formulate a homogeneous solution it
performs air removal all in the final
product bags and then a loquats
into cryopreservation bags and finally
performs an RF seal so the bags are
ready to remove from the system to take
to the controlled rate freezer the
automated cooling is controlled by an
integrated chiller system with the
settable range between 0 and 15 degrees
centigrade we have infrared sensors that
monitor the process temperature for the
incoming materials into the product bag
and there are integrated chilling plates
that contact the mixing bag as well as
the final product bags to keep them at
the set temperature we have automated
mixing for up to three incoming
materials which would typically be sells
some sort of media or buffer to adjust
cell concentration and finally a
cryoprotectant
typically DMSO as Jim had mentioned
previously the device provides automated
dispensing and up to three product bags
in one quality controlled bag the system
is controlled by the operator through a
touchscreen interface and materials are
controlled with an integrated barcode
scanner now we'll dive into some of the
specific features on the finial filling
finish system on the top right you can
see a material bag holder on the outside
of the system this is where you hang
your incoming materials cells media and
cryoprotectants beneath that is
indicated a load sensor
that is what manages the volumes that
are being transferred into the system
and then ultimately into the product
bags that load sensor converts from
weight to volume using the specific
gravity of any fluid you see to
peristaltic pumps as well as some tubing
holders which are used to route the
tubing appropriately on the system the
product bag hang on the left side and
they're integrated into cooling plates
above the product bag holders you can
see automatic automatic RF sealing
valves those valves both control the
flow into each of the product bags as
well as perform a final RF seal so the
bag can be removed there's also a fluid
sensor to detect fluid and air
throughout the process and you see that
mixer and cooling plate which cools the
incoming products and also has
alternating mixing paddles to ensure a
homogeneous solution lower down on the
device you can see the touchscreen
monitor and it's kind of resting place
so that slides out from the system and
that's where the operator provides all
the interaction again through a touch
screen we see towards the right there is
disposable tube routing to ensure that
the tube is coming out of the door
system appropriately and we also have a
handheld barcode reader to scan all
incoming materials the phineus system
uses two disposable sets with different
configurations of product bags the first
configuration on the top shows three
product bags that our origin see as 250
bags and those have a volume range for
cryopreservation from 29 to 70 mils we
also have one quality control bag which
has a volume that the user can define
between 10 and 40 mils the bag on the
right with the conical shape towards the
bottom is the interim bag for mixing and
then the line to the right is where
incoming materials are sterile dock to
bring into the set the set on the bottom
shows a different configuration with
three smaller product bags which allow
volume ranges from ten to twenty eight
mils on the
bag and that said as well.we we do allow
10 to 40 mils in that quality control
bag
so this is a kind of high-level process
flow of how the thinny of filament
finish system executes final formulation
and dispensing into cryopreservation
bags so we break it into three sections
the first is machine preparation an
operator will first log into the machine
and select the protocol the device then
performs a load sensor check to ensure
that the calibration is still valid for
that load sensor the operator will enter
target product volumes for what they
want in the product and QC bags and
target material volumes which is the
amount of incoming material again cells
buffer and cryo typically that will be
introduced into the system the operator
can then scan the barcode on the
disposable set to confirm they're using
the right type and transfer the
disposable set information into the run
report the tubing set is then loaded
onto the finial and then it moves into
the final formulation step so once the
door is closed the system can proceed
and the operator starts by scanning the
barcode on material 1 and ensuring that
it has been connected by a sterile weld
to the same iya tubing set the device
adds material 1 and then if a 2
component or 3 component material
Edition protocol is selected after the
first material is added it's cooled the
temperature is maintained and then a
second material can be added after that
barcode has been scanned if you're doing
a three-component mature material
protocol then you'll scan the barcode on
the third material to ensure that you
have an appropriate material 3 and
that's added into the mixing bag anytime
that fluid is being introduced into the
mixing bag the mixing paddles are
engaging that bag which both holds it up
against the cold plate to control
temperature as well as ensuring a
homogeneous mixture in that bag
once all the mixing and cooling has been
achieved with your up to 3 incoming
materials the fill and finish steps
proceed and that's where first
air is removed from the final product
bags to prepare them for a
cryopreservation and then the material
is aliquot it out into up to the three
product bags and the QC bags the device
then seals those product bags the doors
can be open and the product bags can be
removed and taken to the control Drake
freezer
and with that I would like to open it to
any questions for either dr. Beltre and
myself
thank you Jim and Jeff for your
presentations a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
Jim Beltzer and Jeff you'll answer as
many questions as time permits first
question is what are the current potency
assays used monitor specific MSA number
and function during expansion and
downstream processing well I think the
current potency assays are pretty much
true potency assays are indication
specific so they would be looking for a
relative disease state in a small animal
model or a cell based most
that's either the poster child for
potency houses because there are really
no great potency assays and the flow
markers that we currently use don't
really tell you whether you've got a
hundred percent MSC so I think the
advances in the understanding of your
process is going to be really critical
as well as real-time monitoring so that
you can see changes along the way the
right now we don't have good markers for
thank you is five percent DMSO
sufficient for cryopreservation of all
cells so I I would I would never say
that anything is working for also so
everybody's cells turn out to be
different because the product is the
process as I mentioned earlier in the
discussion so really to determine the
proper level of DMSO would be done
empirically I don't think you with just
a blanket case and it's going to work
for everything
thank you how much is given up in
consistency and viability at this lower
concentration
like I said I think that is a that is a
specific process specific question I
can't answer that as to how much will be
given up by different concentrations of
DMSO that would have to be determined
empirically okay thank you next one is
will the Phineas fill cryo vials for
commercial products currently Cydia is
designed around filling into
cryopreservation bags as was indicated
on that slide so we have two
configurations of disposable set with
product bags either a CS 250 bag which
has a freezing range from 29 to 70
milliliters or CS 25 or CS 50 bag which
has a freezing range from 10
there's
thank you are the cells washed prior to
being processed through the finial
yes in the process you'll notice that
the washing concentrate all precedes the
formula fill and finish functions of the
phineas so in in the typical process you
would harvest yourself you would wash
and concentrate to remove your perhaps
your enzyme
to do any buffer exchanges to
concentrate yourselves and then those
those cells once they are at the proper
concentration probably because you've
already considered what concentration
they need to be at before adding the
DMSO so all of the washing concentrate
would proceed of fitting you use thank
you next one is will finial to do more
than three bags in the future
Antonia from a technology perspective
one of the things we like to maintain
with this device is consistency across
all the product bags and the quality
control bag and that means from when all
your incoming materials have been added
we want to be able to aliquot into the
product bags remove air seal the bags
and get those cellular mixtures to the
controlled rate freezer in a in a
consistent amount of time you do 50 bags
and while we can engineer solutions
there it becomes increasingly more
difficult to prove that your first bag
and your last bag have experienced the
same conditions when you take them to
the controlled rate freezer so plans
right now is to Affinia with the three
product bags and one QC bag thank you
next one is is this fill finish system
currently for sale
the next week Affinia will be available
for sale um we have certain geographies
that are available certainly
english-speaking countries in in North
America some in Asia and follow-on
geographic availability will be in six
months as additional language sets are
added to the device next one is how much
time does the Finney a process require
on average so based on the testing we've
done for our nominal runs the finial
process finishes and in typically 3035
minutes one of the important time
parameters that we like to maintain is
once the amount of time to finish a
procedure from when cells have
experienced contact with cryo
preservative and we enforce restrictions
on off process can complete in less than
25 minutes from when the cells have
first experienced cryo procedure time
does vary though based on targeted
volumes as well as a temperature profile
of incoming materials
thank you dr. belt sir you noted that
approximately 61 percent of cogs is
based on labor and materials and that
current processes lack automation and
manpower for what part or steps of the
process you have the greatest concern
going forward or hope and expectation
for improvement yeah so my biggest
concern and where I think the biggest
gains will be had is actually in
understanding your process so in the
development of as the first one of the
first questions discussed the
development of relevant potency assays
and relevant cell markers is really
critical to the advancement of the
entire field right now I think that the
real-time monitoring is going to give us
data that we haven't had access to in
the past that will try to keep these
processes within the guardrails
better so first things first understand
your process thank you
next one is for Jeff Jeff is it correct
that the Affinia has three product bags
in a QC bag and why is that and you
expect to add more bags to the system in
the future
ensuring previously we are at three
three product bags in a quality-control
bag and that allows us to formulate
three doses for a patient while
maintaining a retain sample so we
enforce a quality control bag for each
procedure and as I touched upon before
we're currently staying with 3 product
bags to ensure consistency across those
bags mainly from a time that cells are
exposed to D
them to the controlled rate freezer
thank you how is the volume measured and
controlled in the product bags so volume
on Vidya is managed in two ways one by
the peristaltic pumps which have
displacement for each turn of the pumps
so we can understand how much fluid has
been pumped by by those peristaltic
pumps in addition that interim mixing
bag hangs on a precise load sensor
uses the specific gravity of your fluid
to convert weight to volume so
throughout that procedure we can manage
the volume and the sets by comparing how
much the pumps have accumulated in
transferring volume as well as the
volume that's been either added to that
mixing bag or taken away from that
mixing bag how long does it take to
complete a full fill or finish cycle or
process
or these procedures typically finishing
in around 30 minutes and we maintain
that time where cryopreserve ative has
been in contact with cells to less than
25 minutes
okay thank you looks like we have time
for one more question why is the volume
limit on the larger disposable set at
174 milliliters when you would expect up
to 250 milliliters using the maximum bag
volume of the set
well one of the important specifications
of what finis ik and deliver into the
product bags is a uniform concentration
of cells and cryo preservative so that
mixing bag is up against a refrigerated
plate to maintain temperature but there
are also two mixing paddles that we use
to keep the cells in suspension and to
create a modulus mixture
that we use we can demonstrate that
critical performance parameter of less
than 5% concentration of variability
across those product bags when we have
up to 174 mils in that mixing bag I
would like to once again thank Jim
Beltzer and Jeff fuel for their
presentations I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor to remote BCT for
underwriting today's educational webcast
until next time goodbye